there she is
yes - yes
and you made a promise it's return the
stark girls to their mother who is now
dead to keep them safe well highest
stock hasn't been seen since her father
was killed but do you think she is
my money isn't dead there's a certain
safety in depth can you say what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season 8
predictions video today I want to answer
some more other questions you left me on
my community tab in my last Q&A video I
did answer the questions that had the
most likes but today I wanted to answer
some of the questions that were posted
late and didn't get many likes at all
that way more people get a chance to
participate I might make another one
next week so keep your eyes open for
that post but let's begin this question
is from Chelsea Oliver and I wanted to
answer her question first because she
said something here that I thought was
very interesting I actually hadn't
considered this before and I don't
recall anyone else ever bringing this up
and I just had to say that I love this
idea
Chelsea's question says do you think
that Jaime could rally ed myrin forces
in the Riverlands and head to Winterfell
with the force of his own and when he
gets there could we see him swearing an
oath to bran to keep him safe by
becoming his shield this is a great
question and first I just want to say
yes I absolutely think he could get Ed
Muir Tolley and tried to rally some
troops before he gets to Winterfell
that way he arrives with extra
reinforcements but I really loved what
you said at the end of the question
could Jamie swear an oath to brand to
keep him safe by becoming his shield I
actually never considered this I have
always said that I believe Jamie will
die by sacrificing himself for one of
the Starks or even Brienne but I do
think the most poetic way for him to
sacrifice himself would be if he did it
trying to save bran considering he did
attempt to murder him in season one for
some reason I have always pictured Jaime
dying in the end and then someone would
fill out his pages in the white book
with all the good deeds that he truly
done you might not know this if you
haven't read the books but Jaime is
constantly thinking about that white
book and how his pages are empty I think
he fears that he will die before he ever
does something honorable
and he will only be remembered as the
man who killed the king he had sworn to
protect mr. Jaime Lannister someone
forgot to write down all your great
deeds but still time is there for a
forty-year-old night with one hand the
sack of King's Landing murdered his King
Aerys ii pardoned by Robert Baratheon
thereafter known as the Kingslayer it's
the duty of the Lord Commander to fill
those pages there's still room left of
mine the reason why I love your idea is
because I can absolutely see him doing
something like that Jaime had already
swore a vow to lady Catelyn that he
would make sure her daughters were
returned home safely that was one of the
reasons why he gave brie and the sword
and armor in the first place but in the
books he gives her more than that he
also gives her a bunch of money so she
can eat and have places to sleep and he
gives her a signed decree from King
Tommen that she can basically use as her
shield as she travels across the
war-torn country now that you say that
about Jaime swearing to protect brand I
think we will see something like that he
won't just show up and say he will help
them fight the dead but I think he could
bend his knee just like Brienne did for
Psalms up and he will pledge his sword
to them when Jaime gave Brienne
Oathkeeper he said something along the
lines of now you can protect Ned Stark's
daughter with Ned Stark's sword when
Jaime shows up he will have the second
half of Ned Stark's sword because Jaime
now has widow's wail he carried that
sword on his hip and pretty much every
episode in season 7 when Jaime gets to
Winterfell he will pledge his sword to
house Stark
and now the stark children will be
protected by all of the Valyrian steel
that once made up Ice House Starks
ancestral Valyrian steel sword how crazy
would it be if Jaime actually became
brain Stark's new Hodor and he stayed at
his side helping him and protect
ding him at all times to make up for
what he'd done in season 1 when he
pushed him out of the tower window
I still think Jamie may die by
sacrificing himself but if he lives I
absolutely believe he could stay in
service to the stark children that's if
they will have him and allow him to stay
that was a great first question so thank
you Chelsea this next one is from Manish
and it has to do with Jaime Lannister as
well Manish says there is speculation
that Jaime will become the 1,000th Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch and help
restore the wall in the order do you see
this happening I have heard this also I
believe Tony Teflon said Jaime would
join the Nights Watch in the end
personally I do not see Jaime becoming
the Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
in my opinion I don't think they will
need a Night's Watch anymore once the
Great War is over if the night King and
his entire army are defeated the wall
will no longer serve its purpose so
there would be no need to guard it
because there is nothing left north of
the wall but let's just say there will
be a Night's Watch at the end if for
some reason they do restore the wall and
keep a guard there
I believe Jorah Mormont will become the
1,000th Lord Commander as we all know
Jorah Mormont's father was the Lord
Commander at Castle black
when John and Sam took the black and
said their vows the reason why Giora
Mormont joined the Nights Watch in the
first place was so that Jorah could
inherit Bear Island earlier than he
should have G or Mormont knew he was
already becoming an older man and he
pretty much lived his life so he wanted
to hand everything over to Jorah he
decided to join the Nights Watch so he
could still provide some kind of a
service but Jorah pretty much spit right
in his father's face when he started
selling poachers into slavery not only
did he embarrass their entire family but
Jorah had to go on the run and give up
everything his father had given him
so now Jorah Mormont was stuck at the
wall for the rest of his life in the
only reason he joined was so Jorah could
take over for him at bear island and now
that Jorah had ruined that it completely
broke his father's heart even though G
or was still serving at the wall I bet
he felt like he joined for nothing
because everything he had sacrificed for
his son was now given up because his son
broke the law but there is something
Jorah could do that would have pleased
his father when G or Mormont was dying
he was laying in samwell tarly arms and
he told Sam that he had one dying wish
he wanted Sam to tell Jorah to take the
black it was his wish his dying wish
I believe if Jorah Mormont lives until
the end he would take the black like his
father wanted Lyanna Mormont now has
control of Bear Island and she isn't
about to just hand that over to Jorah
because he's friends with Danny and John
so I don't know what else Jorah would do
if he did live that long but like I said
I don't know if there will even be a
Night's Watch anymore because if there
is nothing north of the wall then there
is no point of having a wall in the
first place but that's just my opinion
the next question is from Nathan and he
says what do you think about the theory
that the night king will sacrifice his
army of 100,000 in the north and he will
fly south to King's Landing in order to
recruit 1 million people from the city
this was actually in that outline at
read last week basically what this means
is some people think the night king will
send his army to Winterfell while he
flies to King's Landing to try and turn
the 1 million people there personally I
don't think this makes that much sense
if the night King flies the King's
Landing by himself how does he plan on
killing 1 million people when he would
only have his dragon with him if the
night king used his dragon to kill the 1
million people he would then have no way
of turning them into whites because once
the dragon fire kills them they're gonna
turn to ash the only way this would work
is if the blue flame happens to freeze
them then he could turn them before they
unthought I guess but there is no way to
know how that works we saw what the
dragon did to the wall so I'm not sure
how he could use the dragon to help him
turn 1 million people the dragon would
do too much damage to their bodies I
believe the night King will stay right
with his army I think he would be way
too vulnerable if he was by himself even
on a dragon he needs his army with him
that way everyone is distracted by his
100,000 whites while he can be in the
air providing aerial support if he went
to King's Landing by himself on the
dragon he would have to find a way to
kill everyone without doing too much
damage to the bodies that way he could
still turn them into whites but I just
don't see that working the next question
is from Tina north and it says I know
that we are supposed to be getting a
bittersweet ending but wouldn't it be
nice if John had some happiness and Arya
completed her list and bran got his
castle I think I talked about this a
little bit in a previous video but I
don't think the ending is gonna be as
bitter as some people think we will
definitely lose some main characters
sure but haven't we all been expecting
that to happen anyway when they say the
ending is going to be bittersweet I
think it's gonna be more along the lines
of some main characters dying and most
of Westeros being completely destroyed
but there will still be a dream of
spring phase there will be some beloved
characters left that will restore and
rebuild the kingdoms it will leave a
very bitter taste in our mouths at the
end when we fully grasp how many people
died senselessly but in the end all of
the evil rulers will be dead the entire
realm is going to suffer during that
process but I am confident there will be
enough good people alive to build
Westeros into a more civilized and
prosperous place to live than it was
before that's kind of how I've always
seen it playing out the night king will
be defeated
Cersei and Euron will be defeated but we
will probably lose John or Dany in the
process one of them will probably die
but I have a good feeling that
characters like Tyrion Davos ginjury
missandei Brienne and possibly a few
others will live and if so those are the
perfect characters to leave responsible
for instilling new laws in making
Westeros a better society to live
essentially if you think it will end
worse than that please let me know how
you foresee the ending of the series the
next question is from Matt Murdock and
he says is Cersei going to die early
next season so the White Walkers are the
big bad guys or is she gonna make it out
alive in my opinion now what
to say no to both of those questions
Cersei will not die early but she will
die at some point she will not make it
out of this alive and if she did I would
be kind of surprised I think she's been
living on borrowed time for a while now
and her Judgment Day is coming very soon
but she is very resilient and she has
been able to outmaneuver her foes when
push comes to shove the only reason why
I think Cersei will live until the end
of this season is because the night king
is already in the north the night king
is too dangerous to leave unattested
right now especially while John's family
is at Winterfell right in the night
Kings path Jon and Daenerys are already
heading north and they will come
face-to-face with the army of the Dead
very soon we have already seen tons of
evidence that show Winterfell under
attack since the night king is close by
it's most likely him John and Daenerys
are not going to be able to deal with
Cersei while the night king is
destroying the north and turning even
more people into whites they will have
to stop him as soon as possible because
if his army continues to get any bigger
their chances of defeating him decrease
significantly while all of this is going
on Cersei will remain alive and in power
Miguel supports Nick is directing
episodes 3 and 5 since he has directed
some of the other massive battles he
will most likely direct the battles
against the night king in the battle
against Cersei with keeping that in mind
I believe Cersei will die by episode 5 I
can't see her living any longer than
that because I believe King's Landing
will be attacked by episode 5 next
season they have no choice because
there's only six episodes left this next
question is from Christina and she says
was lief and her group the last of the
children of the forest are they gone and
extinct now that they're dead this is a
very good question
and in terms of the television show I
can't give a definitive answer because
we haven't seen every location yet all I
can really say is they did make it seem
like they were the last ones left leaf
and her group of children never
mentioned or even referenced any others
like them so it did appear as if they
were the last of a dying breed if there
are any more children left they would
have to be at the owl of faces
which is a sacred island in the middle
of a lake known as the gods eye which is
in the river lands right next to
Harrenhal that's where the famous
tournament was held and that's where
Aria and Tywin had their scenes together
the Isle of faces is one of the few
locations in the South that still has
weirwood trees because most of them were
cut down and burnt in the south but the
ala phases is where the children of the
forest and the first men agreed to make
a pact to end the wars against each
other when they did this they carved
faces into all the weirwood trees on the
island
that way they could witness the pact
they made together then they formed the
order of the green men so they could
stay there and watch over the remaining
weirwood trees in the south this is a
very special and sacred place so if
there is any children left they would
most likely be here this last question
is from Ezra Lannister and it says do
you think we will see the army of the
warriors of light from a shy in season 8
woken vara play a role I won't guarantee
we will see them but I am very close to
saying that I am pretty sure everyone is
aware of what Melisandre said to Varys
in her final scene she said she was
going to volantis but she was coming
back and there could only be a few
reasons why Melisandre is gonna go there
in the first place it has to be for some
kind of assistance for the Great War or
else she would have no reason to go
there and then come back it would be a
pointless trip unless it is of some kind
of importance we were already introduced
to confer in season 6 so there is a very
good chance we could see her again
can Vora did say some very ominous
things to Varys when they met and I feel
like we should get some closure there I
believe we need to find out what Varys
heard in the flames it has haunted Varys
and shaped him into the man that he is
today he has been too important of a
character for us not to get that reveal
Melisandre in Canberra both may play a
role in that
also we know this story is about ice and
fire there are tons of different
examples I can give but I'm sure most of
you are aware of enough of them one of
the main ones will take place during the
Great War we will have the great other
in the night king representing ice and
we should have real or along with
Daenerys representing fire I don't know
if Melisandre will go to a
shy or not but we do know she said she
was going to volantis and that's where
the fiery hand is located they are a
group of slave soldiers who guard the
red tempo of relora in volantis and the
fiery hand contains 1000 soldiers now I
know that doesn't sound like a lot but
we don't know exactly what kind of
powers they may possess they are slave
soldiers / allure so there is no telling
what they might be capable of they also
carry Spears and they have points on
them in the shape of flames so we could
potentially have these fire soldiers
going up against the night Kings ice
soldiers and that would look pretty damn
cool volantis is also known for having
some of the best blacksmiths who know
how to rework Valyrian steel now I know
there is a much Valyrian still left for
anyone to reforge but I felt like I
should at least mention that I think
there are a number of different reasons
why Melisandre could have went there but
the most logical answer would be to
prepare for the war against the night
King Melisandre is main purpose was to
be ready for this day she has preached
about the darkness coming ever since our
first scene and there's no way she
doesn't play some kind of a big role in
all of this she did till Varys her job
was done because she brought ice and
fire together since she did talk
Daenerys into meeting Jon Snow but
that's not all she's gonna do I made a
video a few months ago where I talked
about Melisandre is endgame and what I
truly think her purpose is I will
actually be updating that video very
soon because I found some amazing
evidence that supports my theory even
more I'm really looking forward to
making that video because I believe I
did find the answer but we shall see if
you have any thoughts or questions of
your own about today's video please
leave them down in the comment section I
would like to hear what you have to say
about some of these things I have to
thank everyone for taking the time to
watch this video especially if you've
made it this far I'm always curious to
know how many people actually listen all
the way through my videos so if you're
still here leave a comment down below
and let me know where you're from you
don't have to be too specific but I'm
interested in knowing what cities or
countries everyone lives in also before
I go I want to thank everyone who
supports my channel on patreon and I
want to give a special shout out to Doug
back who pledged $100
and Dante Williams who pledged $50 I
cannot thank you all enough for how
generous you have been it means more
than you would ever know I hope everyone
has a great day I will see you in the
next one bye
you